Germany Zero Points
felt one hears this sentence in the meantime
more and more often at the
annual Eurovision Song Contest.
but how good or how bad
Germany has in the history of the ESC
actually cut off so far?
since 2,015,
Germany has been involved in the
international
low competition not really covered with rum.
During this time the Germans occupied four times the
very last place and were thereby twice with
0 points in total.
once it was only enough for penultimate place.
only 2,018 Michael could
Schulte with the song You let me Walk
alone get an acceptable 4th place.
since the state of escs in 1956,
Germany has
finished in last place a total of ten times.
worse have only been Norway and Finland so far,
who finished in last place 11 times each.
But the fact is also,
the Germans are not always like this at the ESC
extremely lubricated as in recent years.
actually they have the thing
also won twice before.
composer Ralf Siegel and singer Nicole got
with 1 little peace the 1st place.
2,010 Stefan Rap's discovery Lena
with her earworm
Satellite for Germany triumph.
Germany also finished 2nd four times
and 3rd place five times.
On average
Germany thus even belongs to the
most successful countries,
who have participated in the ESC so far.
this year the singer
Isaac the Germans at the Eurovision Song
Contest represented,
who there with his song
Always on the run wants points.
will be the streak of bad luck from Germany at the
ESC finally end with this song?